what I want to talk about in this video
is one of the darker periods in Chilean
history and depending on your point of
view also one of the darker periods in
American history in it and and what I
want to make clear in this video and it
really applies to every video making
history is be skeptical of everything
that I'm telling you I'm going to do my
best attempt to give a reasonably
accurate series of events and and and
draw connections when they're clear and
also make it clear where there might be
connections and no one is sure but you
should be skeptical and frankly you
should be skeptical of anything anyone's
telling you and I encourage you all to
kind of use this as a scaffold for your
own research for you to look up these
these names and these events and figure
out what actually happened now with that
said let's rewind back to 1970 when
Chile was having an election for
president and they have their election
and it's considered a fairly free and
fair election and one of the candidates
in that election was this gentleman over
here Salvador Allende who is a known
Marxist a known Marxist he has communist
ideologies here he's known he is known
to be sympathetic to what has happened
in Cuba to sympathetic to the Soviets
and so he could you imagine in this
context America is concerned it's in the
middle of the Cold War you have Richard
Nixon president you have Henry Kissinger
is his Secretary of State they are
actively watching this election they
clearly do not want Salvador Allende to
become president all of a sudden a major
country in Latin America being
controlled by a Marxist unlucky for them
Salvador Allende actually does get more
votes than everyone else
he gets 36% of the votes which is a
plurality and just so you know what
plurality means it means you got more
votes than anyone else but not
necessarily the majority of the votes if
he'd gotten 51% of the votes that would
be a majority in this case he didn't get
a majority and the standard procedure in
Chile is that if the no one gets a
majority it goes to Congress and
Congress picks who's president and the
usual thing that they would do is they
would pick whoever has the most the
largest amount of votes they normally
didn't do a runoff so you can imagine
Nixon and Kissinger they're worried so
they kind of get into let's mess with
what's going on in Chile mode and this
part is well-established that they had
this what they called a track one
strategy of actually trying to get the
Chilean Congress to not do what they
normally do to not pick the guy with the
largest number of votes so they were
trying to mess there it didn't seem like
something that they would be able to
pull off the other thing that it looks
like they started to kind of get
involved with through the CIA is they
started to they started to at least
interface it's not clear how much they
actually supported they actually started
to talk to people in the military and
see well how likely is a coup to happen
how likely is a end a to be overthrown
if he becomes president they were
looking for for people who could I guess
keep this this this known Marxist from
becoming president and the number one
problem was this guy right over here the
number brought one problem was this guy
right over here and in this whole video
I would say that Rene Schneider was the
only unambiguously good guy in this
video he was the commander-in-chief of
the Chilean military and he said look I
don't care you know who becomes
president I don't care how much I
disagree with him I don't care how much
pressure the Americans put on me or how
much pressure the rest of the military
puts on me the role of the Chilean
military is not to mess with politics
the role they call them a
constitutionalist the role of the
Chilean military is not to overthrow
people when we don't like them the role
of the Chilean military is only to
defend Chile is only to literally do it
I guess you know and what militaries are
supposed to do what constitutions say
the military is supposed to do and so
you can imagine that the people who
wanted to overthrow
Ind now that he's coming to it looks
like he's going to come to power they
say well you know this guy is not a
convenient guy to have in power he
doesn't like to play the way we play
even though maybe there are other
elements in the military that did want
to do that and so and this is what's a
little bit unclear you have this former
general in the Chilean military who is
who is clearly anti IND and he is also
an
haider because this guy right here
roberto vo he thinks that the military
should be I guess actively overthrowing
dictators and so there is some contact
between him and the CIA it seems like
the CIA may have supplied some support
to him and then maybe got a little bit
freaked out that at least Kissinger
might have gotten a little freaked out
that this guy seemed a little bit of
extreme but remember we're in this
period where I end a was he got thirty
six percent of the votes
Congress is kind of trying to figure out
what they do about it and during this
period there are some people say well
look if Rene Schneider is not going to
take things do though and what's in
their mind the right thing and depose
the eventual I end date
then we'll have to depose Rene Schneider
so you have this plot that's worked up
by Roberto vo to essentially kidnap Rene
Schneider and that would essentially
depose him from being head of the
military and maybe they could put
someone in this place who is more likely
to have a coup more likely to want to
overthrow I end a unfortunately when his
people when this guy's people try to
kidnap Schneider Schneider he's you know
he's got a gun he sees these guys
kidnapping he takes out the gun and then
the kidnappers shoot him several times
and he eventually dies so they
essentially turns into this kidnapping
turns into an assassination of Rene
Schneider and they wanted to kill him
just because or remove him or whatever
just because he essentially wanted to do
his job so he's the only person in this
whole narrative where I'll say he was an
unambiguous he was an unambiguous good
guy now what's not clear is how much of
involvement the Americans or the CIA had
in supporting this this kind of
assassination or this kidnapping of
Schneider it does look like they kind of
knew that something was going on this is
a quote from Kissinger seems pretty well
substantiated where he told Nixon before
a few days before Schneider was
assassinated when Nixon said hey what's
going on in Chile are we are we working
on any you know ways through the
military and are we doing anything about
potentially maybe about Schneider I
don't know look that up for yourself
know how much Nixon may or may not have
known Kissinger told Nixon this looks
hopeless I turned it off nothing could
be worse than an abortive coup so this
quote is interesting because it looks
like they thought about it I mean I
turned it off which implies that at one
point he had it turned on so at one
point they were actively thinking about
working with Roberto vo maybe the
kidnaps Neider maybe to orchestrate
maybe to orchestrate a coup against I
end a but they turned it off so there's
definitely not they're not morally above
doing this type of thing but they
decided that this guy was a little bit
was not as competent as maybe they
thought he should and at least according
to Kissinger he's saying we turned it
off because nothing could be worse than
an abortive coup and it turned out
that's exactly what happened because as
soon as this guy got killed everyone's
like oh my god you have all of these
shady elements who are trying to kind of
overthrow democracy and that actually
put more pressure on on Congress to say
hey we have to let IND become president
so in November he gets inaugurated
President November I n day I n day
becomes president and this is always you
know there's a bunch of different
stories here how much the CIA was
involved the the counter-argument is
like look the CIA would not have wanted
to assassinate Schneider because this
would have only made it make IND all the
more popular they would have only maybe
wanted to remove him and put someone
else there who was more likely to have a
coup against IND later who knows if you
believe what Kissinger's words here it
looks like he you know maybe they
provided some initial support to vo and
then they backed off a little bit who
knows well regardless to say by November
of 1970 Salvador Allende became
president and he started implementing
his kind of Marcos Marxist ideology and
it was didn't go that well the chilis
economy especially if you fast-forward
to 1972 1973 not doing so well he
started doing price fixing he tried to
do the you know the fairly naive
approach of raising salaries while
keeping prices fixed which will
obviously lead to shortages so all
around he wasn't the most popular
president it didn't look like especially
his economic policies were working out
well people who are Pro IND would say
well look it just like what the United
States did to Cuba they started doing
the Chile as soon as they had a Marxist
in charge someone they didn't like the
United States started kind of swinging
its huge economic power around to kind
of hurt the Chilean economy so that this
guy would come out of power I'd lead let
you decide that you fast forward all the
way to 1973 so now I end a has been in
power for about three years things are
not going well for my there are there
are strikes going on he tries to clamp
down on the media a bit there are there
are there is unrest there are people who
definitely do not want him to be
president anymore and you know the
people who who are you know who who
don't think much of the United States
will say hey but the United States the
whole time was kind of actively
undermining I&A and that's probably true
the United States will say no look we
were trying to keep the press free that
this guy was clamping down on Free Press
we were trying to we were trying to keep
things so that there will be another
election so that this guy won't turn
into another Fidel Castro and
essentially just turn chili into
totalitarian communist regime regardless
of which side you take on September 11th
1973 i n days deposed he gets the the
military surrounds the presidential
palace and it is said that he commits
suicide and i put that in quotes because
once again some people believe that he
really did commit suicide some people
believe that he was assassinated and
some accounts say that he committed
suicide with an automatic weapon and
well i guess you could commit suicide
with an automatic weapon but it doesn't
seem like the weapon of choice for many
peoples but I'll leave that once again
for you to decide maybe it's not even
well whether whether or not he committed
suicide or whether he was killed but
regardless is a September 11 he he gets
thrown out of power and once again it's
not clear what role what role the CIA
played they clearly were sympathetic to
the people who wanted to overthrow him
they it clearly were support we're
providing indirect support throughout
i-n days regime to all of the people who
are anti i n day and you could look up
so there actually are some declassified
documents that hint at what the level of
CIA involvement might have
regardless to say I ended this deposed
and this gentleman this gentleman comes
to power right over here augusto
pinochet and he comes to power and he
says look you know this democracy thing
is silly I am the president I am the
commander in chief Chile will be run by
military junta and let me write that
down word write down e Chile will be run
by a hunter and a hunter just means a
government that's run by the military
the military willed it's a military
dictatorship the military is now in
charge of Chile we don't need people to
do silly things like voting anymore and
you could imagine Nixon didn't care so
much that this guy didn't like democracy
but he was happy let me see if I could
put a smile on his face he was happy
that at least Pinochet was not a Marxist
that at least we have we have spread we
have stopped the spread of communism in
Latin America unfortunately and Nixon
with that said he and this is explicit
he wanted to do everything in his power
to make to make Augusto Pinochet
successful especially from an economic
point of view so Nixon does we do the
United States does start does start
supporting Pinochet he's viewed as kind
of an American friend
unfortunately for America and
unfortunately for Chile this guy is one
of those big-time tyrants in history so
he is a tyrant and he starts rounding up
people he starts killing people he
starts just he's one of those people
that anything anyone who had there was a
whiff of communism or a whiff of
political opposition he would round them
up he would round their family up he
would torture people and just to kind of
put some put and this is another picture
of him when he's older and it's amazing
how how gentle some fairly evil people
can look in the world so I'll put some
unambiguous horns on him but he he he
killed many many people and many many
people disappeared and just to give an
idea of what this what you know these
are some of the people who disappeared
and it was anyone from people who are
critical of him people who were
perceived to be left-leaning whatever it
was and he tortured including
women and children and all the rest so
all-around bad guy he stuck around in
Chile as president until 1990 so that
seventeen years and he really stayed in
power until 1998 where he was commander
in chief of the army you can imagine if
the military is in control president
isn't that important of a title
commander-in-chief is so for 25 years he
hung around Chile and he continued to be
kind of this totalitarian guy although
he was a big he liked free markets he
was a capitalist in the traditional
sense and the one I guess silver lining
that if you had to throw silver lining
on Pinochet's regime is that the Chilean
economy actually did well during his
regime is that Chile is considered one
of the success stories economically over
that time period so I'll I'll let you
decide and some people will say oh
that's because Pinochet was a you know
he understood economics he didn't try to
do all this price fixing stuff that I
and they tried to do regardless of the
fact that he was a tyrant at least
people you know the economy was doing
well the other side of the equation
would be well look of course the economy
did well now you had the United States
now you had the United States doing
everything in its power this huge the
largest economy in the world doing
everything in its power to make sure
that Chile's economy thrives while one
of its buddies are in power so I'll let
you decide what's who's right who's
wrong what were the actual what was the
actual involvement of the CIA and Nixon
and Kissinger and all of this mess over
here but I think needless to say that
this was a not so pleasant chapter in I
guess world history